what education is really has not
received a kind of attention that it
deserves I mean president bush in is
when his first campaign for president
was talking about education a lot and he
developed No Child Left Behind but since
then since the past there's no child
left behind we haven't really looked at
education like we should and what I
really think you have to do is you have
to have competition in our education
system and that's very controversial but
I think you gotta allow for the public
schools but you also have to allow for
charter schools you have to allow for
voucher schools so that you know we get
the good schools but you should allow
them to compete against each other and
not to pick and the government pick one
system over the other and you've got
allow for the flexibility and the
options and the choices that people do
and if you have those choices you
compete in everybody knows when you have
two individuals competing against each
other both get better
you